[Musique]
la boule de fort est un patrimoine
culturel vivant autour de la Loire de
Blois à Saint-Nazaire les habitants
pratiquent ce sport en enfilant leur
pantoufles les plus confortables mais la
boule de fort qu'est-ce que c'est une
piste d'à peu près 22 m de long des
boules légèrement déséquilibrées et un
cochonnet qu'on appelle surtout pas
cochonner mais le maître Virginie et
Dominique vont m'initier à ce sport de
pantouflards
se joue en savate mais son somme de
sportifs avant tout d'accord
[Musique]
vous avez plus que ça on va plus
t'appeler Kamini Mika mamie comme
[Musique]
ils ont l'air
on y va
les règles du jeu c'est quoi les règles
déjà c'est toujours passé sur les côtés
jamais traversé le jeu alors je sais
qu'il y a un côté fort côté faible
explique-moi un petit peu le côté fort
c'est lui tu vois là il est un peu plus
creux donc il a moins de force donc ton
côté femme doit toujours être du côté de
la partie incurvée d'accord tu
t'assouplis bien là tu mets
du sol et tu diriges vers ton maître
allez
voilà un peu fort mais c'est bien allez
viens on va polir tes boules
[Musique]
merci pour ce cours de polissage de
boules Dominique
[Musique]
alors Virginie toi qui est la présidente
du cercle de bon accord raconte-moi un
petit peu l'histoire bah de ce lieu déjà
on a fêté les 200 ans l'année dernière
ce lieu là il est créé on a un bail de
depuis des années cette génération en
génération il faut quand même savoir que
les femmes ont été tolérées depuis les
années 90 avant on avait pas le droit
d'amener des femmes à la société de
boules de France
on va pas parler de ce qui était pas
bien on va on va dire bravo messieurs
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce cadran là il
permet de marquer les points lors d'une
Maine une partie t'en dit point bon ben
maintenant j'ai toutes les informations
on va pouvoir commencer la partie
sérieusement
allez c'est parti
oh c'est pas mal
oui
alors mais on n'a pas le droit de crier
dans un jeu de boule de fort
[Musique]
non je suis désolé comme on dit chez
nous l'équipe qui vient de marquer les
quatre points vont aller faire la
vaisselle faire la vaisselle ça veut
dire ramasser les boules de la première
mène poussez les boules à la planche il
y a beaucoup d'expression faire la
vaisselle pousser des boules à la
planche je vais aller faire la vaisselle
c'est parti vous avez vu la boule de
fort et du respect mais en plus ça
évolué les hommes vont faire la
vaisselle je vais t'aider d'un